terme de deux années de travail et de
pré campagne et avec une fréquence pagne
qui était une formidable réussite une
campagne interne qui s'est déroulée
on
va écouter tout de suite christian jacob
qui va nous annoncer en direct le
résultat du congrès a l'air ont
contribué des salles aussi sur le
terrain par tous nos candidats se sont
déplacés les salles étaient étaient
pleines et vous permettrait d'avoir
d'avoir un premier mot pour nos 150
mille militants qui se sont mobilisés
comme comme jamais
la droite non merci pour eux
la droite a retrouvé son adn elle est
populaire est allé solidaire comment
comme on l'est mais très très attaché à
ses valeurs et puis surtout avec
maintenant une vraie équipe de france
près prêt à gouverner prêt à diriger
notre pays c'est donc aujourd'hui pour
nous une formidable
formidable journée journée de
rassemblement journée ou journée l'union
d'unités pour la pour la nation et puis
surtout c'est le jour où nous posons le
premier pas sur le chemin qui va nous
amener à la victoire donc je voudrais
aussi vous adresser ce message pour le
11e 11 décembre compte tenu des
conditions sanitaires évidentes nous ne
tiendrons pas le meeting en physique est
tel qu'il était prévu nous vous
tiendrons au courant dans les jours qui
viennent très rapidement de
l'organisation et du déroulement de la
de la campagne donc je vais maintenant
peut-être arriver c'est peut-être ce qui
vous intéresse aux résultats
[Musique]
eh bien écoutez je voudrais là aussi
avant juste dernière phrase avant de
vous donner les résultats
féliciter très chaleureusement nos deux
finalistes qui ont été remarquables tout
au long de la campagne bravo
et puis y'a 6 y associer pour nous
rejoindre dans un dans un instant
michel xavier et philippe qui ont été
tout aussi remarquable alors voilà les
résultats
donc eric ciotti a recueilli 44
1412 voix 39 % 39 0 5%
merci et bravo
et puis et valérie 69 1326 voire 60
95 60 m
[Applaudissements]
bien mes chers amis je veux bien sûr
exprimé mes félicitations les plus
chaleureuses
les plus sincères à valérie pécresse
valérie vient de gagner cette élection
elle a désormais l'immense
responsabilité
d'amener notre famille politique vers la
victoire
je veux la féliciter avec sincérité
avec amitié mais aussi si tu le permets
valérie avec affection
la campagne a été digne puissante et
audacieuse
des qualités indispensables pour nous
conduire vers la victoire
nos liens valérie son ancien
depuis 2012 où nous avons dirigé
ensemble avec laurent wauquiez la
campagne de françois fillon je veux
demain que nous conduisions tous les
deux ensemble ce grand combat que nous
livrions côte-à-côte cette campagne avec
tous les amis qui nous entoure et que je
salue
nous serons d'ailleurs
dès lundi dans les alpes-maritimes
dans mon village de saint martin vésubie
et dans ma ville de nice pour lancer
cette campagne présidentielle qui va
nous conduire vers la victoire
l'élan l'élan inédit et inattendu
l'élan inédit et inattendu qui s'est
levé derrière ma candidature pour que la
france reste la france s'est renforcée à
l'occasion de ce second tour de notre
congrès notre score dément tous les
scénarios écrits d'avancé
qu'il est une démonstration de plus que
ce sont nos idées les idées d'une droite
claire forte sans compromission qui sont
au coeur des attentes du peuple de
france je veux à cet instant exprimer
une reconnaissance toute particulière et
s'il le permet tent et d'une amitié
profonde sincères et ancien pour
christian jacob qui a été l'artisan
minutieux de la renaissance des
républicains et de la droite
en challenge en saluant également le
président du sénat gérard larcher qui
tient dans la haute assemblée
un cap clair et fort pour notre famille
politique et en y associant la
présidente de notre conseil national
annie jeu de va je veux
exprimer ma gratitude à tous ceux qui
m'ont accompagné
à ma directrice de campagne la sénatrice
alexandra burke est au fond de teint
hamon porte-parole le sénateur stéphane
rudulier aux dizaines de milliers de
militants 44000 je crois cadres et élus
de notre famille politique qui m'ont
témoigné leur confiance
j'ai mené ce combat dans la vérité la
clarté le courage solidement enracinée
dans mes montagnes niçoise et dans ma
terre des alpes-maritimes et surtout
guidée par l'amour puissant d'une nation
qui n'a pas fini d'éclairer le monde
fidèle aux valeurs d'une famille
politique qui a toujours été la mienne
et qui a écrit les plus belles pages de
notre histoire contemporaine
en cet instant je pense à ma famille mes
grands-parents gaulliste mon oncle et
lui résistant des maquis de corrèze ma
mère institutrice mon père commerçant je
pense à mes filles à cette belle
jeunesse de france à qui nous devons
offrir une nouvelle espérance à la place
de l'impuissance immobile du maquereau
10 mhz contre la verticalité
jupitérienne chaotique des manuels
macron nous formerons collectif puissant
de compétences de personnalités une
véritable équipe de france au tour de
valérie
j'appelle à une campagne de clarté
absolue contre le maquereau ni la france
ne se gagne que dans l'authenticité la
sincérité
ce sont les valeurs d'autorité
d'identité de liberté que les français
ont plébiscité et dans des programmes
qui étaient sans doute les plus millaire
valérie il demande de la sécurité contre
l'ensauvagement de la société le respect
de l'identité de notre culture de notre
mode vie face à l'islamisme de la
liberté à travers une réduction des
dépenses publiques et surtout une baisse
massive des impôts je faisais dans cette
campagne le garant de ses attentes et de
ses engagements je suis profondément
convaincu que nous ne gagnerons qu'en
tournant le dos à la prudence source
d'immobilisme une espérance se lève
celle d'un redressement national d'une
france apaisée fière de ses valeurs
fier de son histoire et de sa culture
seuls les républicains pour remporter
nourrir et faire prospérer cette
espérance avec l'ensemble des
républicains derrière notre président
christian jacob derrière désormais
valérie pécresse qui va porter nos
espoirs
ponton fonds dont le socle de la
renaissance
la france vient du fond des âges elle
vit l'avenir l'appel mais elles
demeurent elles mêmes au long du temps
disait le général de gaulle écrivons
ensemble rassemblés unis derrière
valérie pécresse un nouveau chapitre de
notre glorieuse histoire pour nos
enfants et pour que la france reste la
france
[Applaudissements]
gérard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes
le processus de rassemblement des
républicains vient de s'achever et nos
adhérents se sont largement rassemblée
derrière ma candidature je voudrais
d'abord leur dire un grand merci
chers amis
votre confiance me va droit au coeur et
elle m'oblige
je mesure aussi l'audace qui est la
vôtre
aujourd'hui pour la première fois
pour la première fois de son histoire le
parti du général de gaulle de georges
pompidou de jacques chirac de nicolas
sarkozy notre famille politique va se
doter d'une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle
alors je pense à toutes les femmes de
france aujourd'hui et jeudi là aussi
merci aux adhérents merci d'avoir eu
cette audace et je vais m'en montrer
digne oui mes amis je vous le dis
solennellement je vais tout donner je
vais donner ma force je vais donner mon
énergie je vais donner ma détermination
pour faire triompher nos convictions
j'adresse à christian jacob
et à toute l'équipe des républicains
annie genevard mais ils sont tous ici je
voudrais adresser aussi à gérard larcher
à damien abad à bruno retailleau toute
l'équipe des républicains mes
félicitations pour l'organisation de ce
congrès qui a montré aux français le
visage d'une très belle équipe de france
enraciné dans les territoires
professionnels et cette équipe je veux
la rassembler aujourd'hui
notre unité fait notre force
alors bravo à tous pour vos belles
campagnes
merci cher eric merci de ton soutien
aujourd'hui franc et massif comme toi je
sais ta constance à défendre notre
civilisation millénaire je sais que tu
te fais l'avocat
indéfectible à la fois de l'ordre et de
la liberté qui sont deux valeurs
cardinales de notre famille politique
alors ensemble je m'y engage nous allons
restaurer la fierté française et
protéger les français
notre rassemblement ce ne sera pas que
des mots ce seront des actes alors oui
cher philippe
ensemble nous allons sauver les services
publics en grande souffrance de
l'hôpital à l'école en passant par la
justice
oui cher xavier
ensemble nous allons défendre la justice
sociale
revaloriser le travail et recoudre les
fractures de la société française oui
cher michel ensemble nous allons
remettre la france au premier rang des
nations et nous allons refonder l'europe
notre rassemblement je veut l'étendre à
toutes les figures et les talents de la
droite les talents du centre mais aussi
les talents d'ailleurs à tous les
républicains sincères qui se
reconnaîtront dans notre projet pour la
france
aujourd'hui j'ai une bonne nouvelle mais
chers amis la droite républicaine est de
retour la droite les convictions la
droite des solutions
elle part avec une volonté implacable
parce que la france ne peut plus se
permettre d'attendre
notre grand défi ça va être de refaire
nation
recréer ce sentiment
d'être tous pour un et un pour tous en
revenant indivisible la france
redeviendra invincible je la veux
respecter partout dans le monde je serai
l'avocate d'une europe moins naïve et
d'une mondialisation plus régulier et
plus juste je serai toujours intraitable
dans la défense des intérêts de la
france mais la france ne sera forte à
l'extérieur que si elle est forte à
l'intérieur
aujourd'hui je ressens la colère d'un
peuple d'un peuple de france qui se sent
impuissant face à la violence et à la
montée du séparatisme islamistes qui se
sent menacée menacé dans ses valeurs et
ses modes de vie par une immigration
incontrôlée
emprisonné aussi sous le poids écrasant
de la bureaucratie et de la dette
je ressens l'angoissent du lendemain des
millions de français qui peinent de plus
en plus à joindre les deux bouts et de
ce qu'ils voient menacés par une
mondialisation sans règle nos industries
et notre agriculture
je veux leur dire que rien n'est fichu
nous ne sommes condamnés ni au désordre
ni au déclin notre pays regorge de
talents regorge d'énergie ce n'est pas
la france qui est en cause c'est son
système avec son immobilisme politique
et sa lâcheté à agir clairement et
fortement n'est un système ça se change
et un président ça se change à 6
[Applaudissements]
et c'est précisément ce que nous allons
faire
alors oui cette élection présidentielle
je me suis préparée je
porterai un projet de franche rupture
j'ai le courage de dire et la volonté de
fer je n'aurai pas à la main qui tremble
face aux adversaires de la république
nous renverserons les blocages
administratifs qui dégradent la qualité
de nos services publics et qui entravent
nos entreprises nous restaurerons le
travail et le mérite
je veux une france solidaire pas une
france d'assister
nous redresserons les finances de la
france car il est immoral de léguer de
laisser la dette submergée l'avenir de
nos enfants nous irons à la conquête de
la croissance une croissance nouvelle
appuyé sur l'innovation et sur une
écologie de progrès nous produirons plus
et mieux nous exigerons des règles du
jeu équitables et nous gagnerons les
batailles économiques sociales et
environnementales
mes chers compatriotes
aujourd'hui
tout commence je veux faire se lever un
espoir
lundi je reprendrai mon tour de france
pour aller vous rencontrer et vous
convaincre et ça commencera
effectivement dans la vallée de la
vésubie sans faux fuyant je dirai la
vérité sur les défis qui nous attendent
et sans relâche je proposerai des
solutions audacieuses pour nous
redresser
je ne serai pas une présidente du zig
zag et de la godille politique qui dit à
chacun ce qu'il a envie d'entendre entre
le président sortant et moi il y a plus
qu'une différence de ligne politique
il y a une différence de nature
emmanuel macron n'a qu'une seule
obsession c'est plaire moi je n'ai
qu'une seule passe on sait faire
[Applaudissements]
je le dis aussi à tous les français
lassés des paroles sans lendemain
exaspérée de l'impuissance publique et
tenter par marine le pen ou eric zemmour
nul besoin d'être extrémiste pour être
offensif
nul besoin d'être insultant pour être
convaincant vous le savez les marchands
de peur ne sont jamais efficace dans
l'action et dans notre histoire aucun
diviseur n'a été un sauveur alors
contrairement aux extrêmes nous allons
tourner la page mach macron mais sans
déchirer les pages de l'histoire de
france
j'irai aussi à la rencontre de tous ceux
qui hésitent encore pour leur prouver
que nos solutions sont les bonnes
jamais la france n'a eu autant besoin
d'autorité de liberté et de dignité
je donne rendez vous à toutes celles et
tous ceux sur moi c'est les bavardages
et de l'amateurisme de notre
gouvernement je donne rendez-vous à la
france qui travaille à la france qui
veut plus pour ses enfants mais aussi
pour nos aînés parce que la famille et
pour moi le socle de la société je donne
rendez vous à cette france qui réclame
éducation santé sécurité et emploi je
donne rendez vous à notre jeunesse à nos
créateurs à nos entrepreneurs à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui doutent qu'ils
viennent veulent que en france pour eux
tout redevienne possible je donne rendez
vous aux français qui refuse de céder
aux cassandre du grand des classements
ce qu'ils nous disent que seul le passé
était grand je crois à l'avenir de la
france rendez vous donc à tous les
patriotes de toutes origines et de tous
bords
cette campagne
c'est le combat d'une vie est avec vous
je vais le gagner
[Applaudissements]
la france est devenue un peu zle nous
allons la réparer rétablir son unité la
france a été abîmée nous allons lui
redonner le sens et l'autorité qu'elle
l'attend la france a été déclassé nous
allons lui rendre le souffre le souffle
et la grandeur qu'elle mérite la france
est une exigence mes chers amis est ce
que je vous propose c'est une belle et
une immense aventure nous allons rendre
à notre pays son unité sa dignité et sa
fierté vive la république vive la france
[Applaudissements]
figaro la ville et
14h50 vous pouvez voir vous venez de
voir en direct donc l' annonce du
résultat du congrès des républicains
s'est donc valérie pécresse qui l'a
emporté avec 61% des voix contre 39 %
pour eric ciotti vous voyez sur les
images qui nous sont fournies par par la
fp
une photo plutôt rassembler donc des des
ténors des républicains et puis donc des
quatre autres candidats au congrès déchu
qui se trouve qui se situe juste à côté
de la victorieuse pour commenter cet
événement en direct derrière sa webcam
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir carl meeus
bonjour karl
bonjour oui alors vous êtes rédacteur en
chef du figaro magazine merci d'être sur
figaro live aujourd'hui est-ce que
première question car là ce que c'était
une surprise pécresse grande gagnante
non c'était la favorite du scrutin parce
que si on additionnait les scores de
tous deux son score plus celui de ceux
qui la soutenaient et en l'occurrence
c'était tous les candidats qui n'ont pas
été qualifiés elle était au soir du
premier tour à 75 % des voix donc là
elle termine à 61% c'est une belle
victoire
c'était attendu il ya eu une
mobilisation un peu plus forte pour eric
ciotti sur ces dernières heures puisque
le scrutin avait démarré pan second tour
à 8 heures du matin mais l'écart était
beaucoup trop important pour lui pour
pouvoir l'emporter
merci car justement on va on va parler
d'eric ciotti qui était un peu la grande
surprise on va dire du premier tour donc
il a terminé avec avec 39% des voix
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on imagine qu'ils
qu'elle adhérents enfin deux cas les
adhérents ont plutôt voté vers eric
ciotti plutôt que valérie claisse puis
qu'il a eu plus de voix on va dire au
second tour
il ya peut-être une partie de gens qui
n'avaient pas voté au premier tour qui
se sont mobilisés on imagine qu'une
partie de ceux qui avaient peut-être
voter pour michel barnier ou xavier
bertrand qui eux ne se sont pas
mobilisés
la surprise eric ciotti au premier tour
elle est venue parce que au départ quand
il est candidat tout le monde pense que
c'est un petit candidat un peu comme
philippe juvin et qu'il est là plus pour
porter des idées et négocier
éventuellement un accord pour le
candidat qui est qualifié au second tour
est en fait au fur et à mesure de la
campagne avec les débats où il a il a
imposé sa ligne il était le seul sur
cette ligne très très à droite et en
plus les autres candidats sont sont plus
ou moins venus sur sa ligne à chaque
fois et c'est ça qui a séduit une frange
de l'électorat alors on peut pas savoir
et c'est dommage parce que on aurait
bien aimé avoir une répartition
géographique pour voir si le vote ciotti
se répartissaient
équitablement sur l'ensemble de la
france ont été très localisés sa
fédération les alpes-maritimes est une
des plus grosses fédérations de dlr donc
c'est là qu'il a fait le plein de voix
mais il a forcément eu des voix d'autres
départements
alors si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes
en direct pour commenter donc les
résultats enfin le résultat définitif du
congrès l r vous savez c'était cette
primaire interne qui qui devait donner
le droit aux adhérents et l'air de voter
de choisir leur candidat pour 2022 et
donc c'est valérie pécresse qui l'a
emporté avec 61% des voix alors à lire
les tchats des différents fin des
différentes plateformes sur lesquelles
on est en direct aujourd'hui donc sur
lefigaro.fr et sur youtube il ya on va
dire deux salles deux ambiances pour
permettez moi l'expression mais
effectivement sur lefigaro.fr il ya de
nombreux
internautes fidèles de figaro l'âge qui
salue la prestation de valérie et il ya
également boris godounov qui nous dit
bravo valérie ou encore kris kross qui
lui dit qu'elle a effectivement un très
bon bilan et qu'il est satisfait de ce
résultat en revanche sur youtube c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt l inverse la
tendance des commentaires et de dire que
valérie pécresse équivaut à emmanuel
macron qu'est ce que vous en pensez car
mu
que au fond 61 40 39 c'est un bon score
pour valérie pécresse mais ça montre un
parti qui est coupée c'est à dire
qu'effectivement la droite de valérie
pécresse n'est pas la droite d'eric
ciotti eric ce titre dès le début a dit
dans un second tour macron zemmour je
vote et moore il ne cesse de dire que
eric zemmour et son ami et donc fait des
clins d'oeil appuyé à eric zemmour en
revanche valérie pécresse de son côté a
été très clair
c'est sa droite ce n'est pas celle
d'eric zemmour et encore moins celle de
marine le pen et même si l on l'a vu
dans son discours on l'a entendu dans
son discours elle est très critique
envers emmanuel macron
dans un second tour avec eric zemmour
marine le pen il n'y aura pas
d'ambiguïté sur son choix donc là la
difficulté que va rencontrer les élèves
que vont rencontrer les l'air
aujourd'hui ça va être de réussir cette
unité on la voit au niveau des
dirigeants puisque là tous les candidats
battus au premier tour et eric ciotti se
sont retrouvés aujourd'hui derrière
valérie pécresse et christian jacob mais
est ce que ce sera la même chose pour
les adhérents est-ce que voilà ceux qui
ont adhéré pour eric ciotti pour faire
valoir leurs idées vont se mettre
derrière valérie pécresse ou au
contraire vont partir pour rejoindre
l'aventuré reg zemmour pourquoi pas
peut-être lé aventures de marine le pen
c'est là tout l'enjeu de voir si les
élèves vont être solide dans un contexte
où malgré tout le parti et quand même un
peu coupé en deux vous pensez donc ces
images ces photos qu'on a vu qu'on a vu
juste juste après le discours de valérie
pécresse
cash on va dire
la vérité on va dire est ce que vous
pensez que le rassemblement n'aura
finalement peut-être pas lieu autour de
valérie pécresse
au niveau des dirigeants le
rassemblement a eu lieu s'est fait sans
difficulté et il tiendra la difficulté
ça va être de convaincre maintenant pour
valérie pécresse convaincre les
adhérents qui ont voté eric ciotti et
les sympathisants de droite et les
électeurs quelle est la bonne candidate
que contrairement à ce que dit marine le
pen elle n'est pas aussi proche que ça
de d'emmanuel macron et d'ailleurs c'est
tout le sens de son discours aujourd'hui
elle a bien compris la menace et c'est
pour ça qu'elle a tapé sur emmanuel
macron avec cette formule qu'à mon avis
on va retenir qui sait la différence des
manières de macron entre emmanuel macron
et moi et une différence de nature
emmanuel macron est une seule obsession
clair moi j'ai une seule passion faire
qui était son slogan de campagne et il
va falloir qu'elle aille sur le terrain
très vite elle va dès lundi sur les
terres d'eric ciotti pour démontrer que
voilà elle ne sera pas celle qui peut
amener des voix à emmanuel macron au
second tour mais en revanche celle qui
peut battre emmanuel macron dès le
premier tour alors vous avez évoqué son
discours il y avait également certaines
à une pique adressée évidemment à eric
zemmour aussi un petit peu plus tard
lorsqu'elle a dit les marchands de peur
ne sont jamais efficace dans l'action
est-ce que vous pensez que certains
électeurs qui ne savent pas trop où se
positionner qui sont à droite mais sa
façon à droite ou à la droite de la
droite peuvent être ré embarqué celle et
l heure où ils seront défis sont
définitivement perdus aux extrêmes
non c'est tout l'enjeu d'une campagne
électorale on sait que là pendant quatre
mois il va y avoir des débats il va y
avoir des meetings il va y avoir des
affiches des slogans et ça fait bouger
les électeurs
souvenez-vous en 2016 à cette époque la
halle à l'issue de la primaire françois
fillon devait faire d'après les sondages
au moins 29 voire 30% dans la l'élection
en avril 2010 est bon finalement il
échoue en dessous de 20% ça veut dire
qu'il ya il ya 10 % du corps électoral
tel qu'il est et sondé à ce moment là
qui a bougé
donc l'objectif de valérie pécresse là
c'est de faire bouger tous ces électeurs
de droite qui sont partis pour une
certaine catégorie chez emmanuel macron
pour les autres sont partis chez marine
le pen certains dans l'abstention et
d'autres ont été séduits par la pré
campagne d'eric zemmour et donc ça
aujourd'hui et dans les mois qui
viennent jusqu'au 10 avril son enjeu
c'est de leur prouver que les
républicains à travers elles ont un
discours qui peut les les séduire la
difficulté c'est d'avoir un discours
c'est pas un seul discours ces deux
discours un discours économique qui fait
revenir les électorat de droite
l'électorat de droite qui sont qui est
parti
vers emmanuel macron et un discours
régalien pour ceux qui sont partis vers
eric zemmour et marine le pen et donc il
faut réussir ce mix
carl meeus qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
du coût des quatre autres perdants on va
dire de ce congrès l air est ce qu'ils
vont faire campagne jusqu'au bout
derrière valérie pécresse est-ce que ça
a été signée charte et j'entends bien
entre eux est ce qu'ils sont tenus de
rester jusqu'au 10 avril unie et
rassemblée derrière valérie pécresse est
ce que par exemple ils ont dit les des
postes en fonction de leur ordre
d'arrivée dans ce congrès si jamais
valérie pécresse arrive à la fonction
présidentielle par exemple
alors il ya deux questions première
question est ce que ils doivent rester
unis en théorie oui ils ont signé un
ils se sont engagés à respecter le vote
des électeurs qui est quand même
relativement claire fait 69 mille voix
44000 dont il n'y a pas de discussion
possible
donc ils se sont tous engagés à soutenir
la candidate désignée après vous savez
en politique malheureusement on connaît
cet adage les promesses n'engagent que
ceux qui les reçoivent et on a
l'expérience notamment chez les verts et
au parti socialiste de gens qui ne
respectent pas leurs leur engagement
puisque manuel valls qui avait signé le
même engagement pour soutenir benoît
hamon est parti voter
et faire la campagne des manuels macron
donc j'allais dire voilà ils sont
moralement tenue mais politiquement
peut-être tout va dépendre de la
campagne de valérie pécresse et et si on
est cynique eu des scores qui lui sont
promis par les sondages d'ici le mois de
janvier
après paris la deuxième question mais en
l'état actuel des sondages valérie
pécresse n'était même pas la
personnalité préférée des français dans
son ensemble quand il était son dea sur
kippour qui vous voteriez à l'instant t
cette et xavier bertrand qu'il était en
tête donc oui vous avez raison mais au
second tour déjà
avant de démarcher des sceaux
alors vous avez entièrement raison mais
les compteurs sont remis à zéro depuis
14h30 aujourd'hui
j'imagine que nos amis sondeurs sont
déjà sur le terrain a essayé de de
déceler les intentions de vote pour les
uns et les autres parce que là il va y
avoir une surexposition médiatique de
valérie pécresse donc elle va
fatalement forcément mécaniquement
progressé dans les sondages à la fois en
popularité en confiance et j'imagine
aussi en intentions de vote les gens ne
la ne la mettez pas au même niveau que
j'allais versant pour home ou plusieurs
raisons peut-être qu'il ne l'apprécié
pas on le verra mais aussi qu'elle était
partie plus tard en campagne donc les
gens l'avaient moins identifié comme une
candidate elle avait moins fait de
médias comme xavier bertrand c'était sa
stratégie au départ de s'imposer par les
sondages
en creusant l'écart définitive pas là de
manière tellement forte que au fond il
découragé ses adversaires c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui lui avait dit plus tu te
lances tôt plus tu pourra monter et
situe à 18 dans les sondages à la
rentrée tu peux estimer avoir plié le
match sauf qu'il n'a jamais été à 18
donc on voit bien que là
les choses les les pendules sont forts
il faut attendre les prochaines vagues
pour voir si valérie pécresse a pris
des points
c'est justement son enjeu est ce que des
électeurs qui étaient chez macron parce
que un électeur de droite ne trouvait
pas son compte estimé qu'il y avait une
division au sein de la famille des
républicains et peut changer d'avis
maintenant se disant ça y est il ya une
candidate elle a un discours qui me
plaît donc je reviens vers elle et même
chose pour des gens qui seraient partis
chez chez eric zemmour en se disant
tiens mais après tout sur la sécurité
sur l'immigration elle a tenu des propos
assez ferme
je lui accorde mon vote
sur le fond rapidement de son de son
programme de 2 de sa candidature quels
sont ses atouts majeurs à valérie
pécresse pour cette course à la
présidentielle
alors un des atouts il s'est vu dans la
campagne c'est qu'elle a un projet qui
était déjà très bien ficelé très
cohérent à la fois en termes économiques
où elle était sur un peu de
redistribution salariale pour les bas
salaires sur suppressions de postes de
fonctionnaires on sait qu'à droite c'est
ça fait partie des éléments qui sont
importants pour pour séduire l'électorat
et en même temps pas le même nombre que
donnait françois fillon qui avait donné
un chiffre très élevé de 500 milles sur
le quinquennat elle est un peu en
dessous sur 200 milles avec en plus deux
cent cinquante mille mais avec un
recrutement de 50 milles sur d'autres
postes c'est ça qui est aussi
intéressant c'est que elle n'est pas
dans un manichéisme
considéré qu'il voit là il ya trop de
fonctionnaires donc fort on en supprime
est partout elle a identifié des
endroits et on le sait notamment sur la
santé où c'est important et puis elle a
un volet régalien qui est assez assez
fort puisque de l est pour une réforme
de la constitution pour pouvoir
lutter contre l'immigration notamment et
en termes de sécurité cette proposition
qui a fait beaucoup parler de peine
différente selon le quartier où on
habite alors on verra évidemment si ces
propositions la passe le mur de conseil
constitutionnel dont on voit bien que ça
ça perturbe juridiquement d habitude
mais en tout cas ce sont des
propositions suffisamment forte pour
être retenu et faire parler oran c'est
dans une campagne présidentielle
l'important au delà des propositions ces
deux d'être au coeur du débat que tout
le monde débattent de vos provisions en
cours ou en compte mais en tout cas de
se placer au centre des débats et sur la
forme rapidement est ce qu'on sait si
elle va garder la même équipe parce que
encore être entouré de monsieur
stefanini par contre pardon
pour la mener à la victoire ce que ça va
bouger
alors la logique ça serait qu'elle garde
patrick stefanini c'est quand même
l'homme des campagnes réussies c'est
celui qui était directeur de campagne
quand jacques chirac a été élu il a
ensuite
mené une autre campagne pour les
régionales pour elle donc et celle ci où
tout le monde a loué son sens de
l'organisation son sens de la
préparation et je pense qu'il n'est pas
étranger à la victoire de valérie
pécresse
ce qui est important c'est de voir si
elle intègre des gens d'autres
sensibilités on a vu là qui à une
réconciliation qui s'est opéré au niveau
des candidats maintenant est ce qu'elle
va prendre des des bonnes volontés des
gens qui étaient prêts à va qui sont
prêts à travailler pour elle et qui
viennent des autres sensibilités de la
droite c'est là que ça va être
intéressant de voir comment elle compose
son équipe
françois fillon avait avait eu du mal à
ouvrir
se souvient que même par rapport à alain
juppé et nicolas sarkozy les gestes
n'avait pas été fait là
l'ailer instruits par l'expérience on
fait tout ce qu'il fallait aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir
passer à l'étape d'après sans qu'on
puisse dire qu'il ya des gens qui sont
chagrinés
est ce qu'on s'est un petit peu le quel
est le programme pour la suite elle a
annoncé enfin c'est christian jacob qui
l'a annoncé au début donc que le grand
meeting du rassemblement prévu samedi
prochain et est annulé pour des raisons
sanitaires si je me souviens bien
comment comment elle va faire campagne
qui a fait pas de deux meetings comme sa
façon la question va se poser pour tout
le monde
pour le coup à part les deux meetings
qui ont lieu ce week-end de jean-luc
mélenchon et eric zemmour
la question se posera dans la campagne
pour tous les autres je pense qu'au delà
de la question sanitaire qui est
totalement légitime puisque de façon ça
faisait plusieurs jours que les l'air
s'inquiétait des mesures que le
gouvernement pouvait prendre après le
conseil de défense sanitaire de lundi
notamment sur des jauges je pense que
c'est aussi une question d'opportunité
et peut-être même de coûts financiers
c'est à dire que commencer sa campagne
avec un meeting le 11 décembre qui
plombe un petit peu les comptes c'était
peut-être pas la meilleure solution
d'autant plus que l'idée qu'ils avaient
au départ de ce meeting c'était un
meeting avec
les les battus de la prime et du congrès
donc ça faisait vraiment une litanie de
discours le 11 décembre à un moment où
les gens n'avaient peut-être pas la tête
complètement encore dans la campagne on
n'est pas loin des fêtes de noël il ya
le coc vite qu'ils qui reprend le dessus
sur les discussions médiatique donc au
fond ils se sont dits l'image du
rassemblement elle est aujourd'hui
elle était faite il vaut mieux attendre
des meetings en janvier et à ce
moment-là janvier février c'est le
moment où les gens commencent à basculer
dans la campagne
les français est l'exemple qui est
souvent donné ses discours de le grand
meeting de nicolas sarkozy en 2007
mi-janvier qui lance sa campagne
victorieuse est d'ailleurs françois
hollande en 2012 sera pareil fin janvier
un grand meeting là aussi qui lance sa
campagne sur la dernière ligne droite
donc il vaut mieux un bon quand un bon
meeting en janvier que un meeting
en décembre à un moment où les gens ont
la tête ailleurs
oui en attendant elle elle sera
l'invitée du coup je crois du du journal
télévisé de 20 heures de tf1 ce soir
merci beaucoup car mes yeux d'avoir été
avec nous en direct
pour cet événement politique on vous
retrouve donc dans les pages du figaro
magazine quant à moi je vous dis à très
vite pour un prochain direct sur figaro
live je remercie ryad b qu'hier à la
réalisation et sasha black arms and pour
la modération merci à tous pour vos
commentaires vous étiez nombreux j'ai
pas pu tout suivre tellement il y avait
de deux débats denses et de chat à
bientôt pour un prochain direct